We will now turn our attention to
the Datastore Commit Process. This process describes
to consistency rules for storing data. Datastore
has two consistency models, Eventual Consistency and Strong
Consistency. Let's look at these in more
detail. In this use case diagram we have
three things. Your Application, the datastore API
that your application calls and the datastore backend,
which performs work that your application is not involved
in. When your application wants to store an entity,
it performs a put operation towards the datastore API.
The datastore backend then writes this entity to a
log. When the write is completed, control is turned
back to your application. At this point the Datastore
backend has promised to write the entity to Datastore.
Observe however that the entity has not been written yet.
It has only been written to a log.
The Datastore backend now goes through to work to
make everything consistent. It does this by using the
login information to update the entity storage and then
it updates all the indexes. So observe that
when control is returned to your application, datastore may
not have done all the work required for the
data to be updated. Is this good or bad?
Well it's good, because this means that you have
less latency in your application. But the question now
becomes, what happens if a query is issued that
would retrieve the data your application just requested to
put into data store? Well, with eventual consistency the
data store API will not wait for this to
happen. So it only considers matching data that already
exists. That is data, that was already in data store
prior to your put call. And then it
returns that result. That's why it's called eventual
consistency. Queries will be eventually consistent with put
operations performed to what's the data store API.